here's how to retire
with a million dollars if you start
investing in your 20s 30s
and beyond you're in your 20s certain
people are in their 30s
paul just turned 40. congrats here's how
you retire with a million dollars let's
assume you're starting with no
savings so you're starting from the
bottom now you're here
and that your investments will return
six percent annually and that you will
plan to retire at 67. so this is simply
just a case example here okay right
if you start saving at 20 you'll need to
stash 319
a month toward retirement can we pull
that up thank you
or about 80 a week is 80 a week possible
i think so
i don't think that's crazy at age 20 and
you will hit your million dollars in 47
years
again this is this is assuming that
you're going to retire at age 67. if
you're age 20
stash 319 a month that's 80 bucks a week
you're a millionaire in 47 years that's
that's uh based on six percent annual
return if you start at age 30 here's
where
like the age and compound interest
really becomes a thing if you start at
age 30
you'll need to put away nearly double
what you did at age 20 now that's 600
bucks a month and you'll get there in 37
years
okay now if you're 40 with no savings
that number jumps up significantly paul
i want you to pay attention here
you need to save 1200 bucks a month
to reach retirement a millionaire
retirement that's almost quadruple if
you started at 20.
and if you're 50 you need to start
saving
2 800 bucks a month if you're 50 and you
have no savings this article says
but there's hope if you're 50 and you
have no money you haven't started saving
at that point i don't know
at that point there's only a couple
hopes one of them's bob and he's dead
and uh i don't know the quicker and
younger you start
the better and here the the the article
this is by the way a cnbc article
as you see investing lets you take
advantage of the power of compound
interest
which means you're not only getting
returns on your invested money
but you're getting returns on your
returns i always say this
compound interest is your money making
money on your money making money and
your money making money on your money
compound interest uh albert einstein or
as paul likes to call it alfred einstein
he uh what he he called
compound interest the eighth wonder of
the world he says
he who understands it earns it
he who doesn't understand it pays it
that's essentially his quote i don't
know if you want to pull that up
but i know 47 years is a long year from
a long time from now if you're 20
37 is a long time if you're 30 27
but you know people say life is short
life is short
no life is long
you know if you have a freak accident
and you die or you know overdose
something crazy freak accident yeah life
can be short i hear you
but we are now living longer than any
generation in u.s history in world
history
like you can make it to 8 80 90 100 no
problem these days life is long
okay so save that money if you enjoyed
that short clip from the sauce cast
click here to watch another click here
to watch the full episode or just stay
[Music]
broke